[Musik]
anfang november wird der autor clemens
setz in darmstadt den büchner preis
verliehen bekommen
die deutsche akademie für sprache und
dichtung begründet das so ich zitiere
jetzt aus dieser jury begründung seine
bisweilen verstörende drastik sticht ins
herz unserer gegenwart weil sie einem
zutiefst humanistischen impuls folgt
diese menschenfreundlichkeit verbindet
clemens setz mit einem enzyklopädischen
wissen und einem reichtum der
politischen und sprach schöpferische
imagination das wollen wir alles
natürlich von ihm wissen und dann folgt
noch etwas mit radikaler
zeitgenossenschaft was vielleicht auch
ein bisschen damit zu tun hat dass
clemens setz öfter in den sozialen
medien anzutreffen ist auch das werden
wir ihn gleich fragen heute ist nämlich
zu gast bei uns im podcast
wahrscheinlich erreichen wir ihnen graz
ruhr geboren wurde und auch liebt hallo
clemens setz und natürlich herzlichen
glückwunsch zum büchner preis vielen
dank und hallo ich bin nicht in graz
sondern in wien
auch dort im die besten grüße wenn die
nobelpreise vergeben werden dann sitzen
die wichtigsten oder vielleicht auch nur
die edelsten autoren der welt vor ihrem
telefon und warten auf einen anruf
wer ist denn du erfahren dass du den
büchner preis gewonnen hast
ja ja ich habe definitiv nicht gewartet
drauf also mann erich wenn ihnen also
ein sessel gesessen und dann kamen ganz
ziemlich spät abends ein anruf und
ja da hat der herr osterkamp
präsident der akademie mir das
mitgeteilt das war sehr also ich hab
schon gedacht dass es
zu kurzen moment habe ich gedacht das
ist ein witz oder falsch aber dann denkt
man doch eine ja wer soll das warum
sollte das jemand machen und dann dann
freuen kann man sich schon freuen also
aber ja also ein bisschen unwirklich war
es schon
und man wird dann auch gefragt nehmen
sie den preis an und hat dann für einen
moment so diese diese diese
bombenexperte spreng taste in der hand
was wäre wenn man nein sagt und was
würde dann passieren
kann natürlich nimmt man das ähnlich und
hat doch gar nicht vor aber
roddick kann mir dichter vorstellen die
das auch machen würden vielleicht ja ich
hätte es nicht vorgehabt aber trotzdem
hat man dann kurz diese bizarre macht
für eine sekunde ein moment in dem alles
möglich ist ja
ursprünglich hast du ja mal mathematik
studiert das liest man überall wolltest
wo lehrer werden also jedenfalls das
dorf lehramt studiert auch germanistik
und was man auch immer wieder liest ist
das ernst jandl dich dann zur literatur
gebracht hat wie genau muss ich mir das
denn vorstellen was hat einst die andere
da getan
ja das war schon kurz nach dem tod von
ernst jandl und
da habe ich überhaupt
erst zu lesen begonnen also dass oder
kurz davor hatte ich so ein bisschen zu
lesen begonnen und es war recht spät im
leben ich habe nie romane oder gedicht
oder irgendwas gelesen bis ich 17 war
sodass es war schon recht spät das heißt
ich hatte nie diese erfahrung zuletzt
leute diese sind herr der ringe und dann
so ganz hinein kippen in einem buch das
gab es in meinem leben gar nie aber dann
hatte ich eben einmal ein gedicht vor
mir
und habe bis zu dem zeitpunkt gedichte
schon ganz lustig gefunden vor allem
wenn sie parodistisch und humorvoll
waren das war für mich so eine art von
also und wieso so kleine sprüchlein
kleine lustige boynton witze und habe
das nur auf der ebene gelesen und dann
gab es ein gedicht das heißt die
morgenfeier auf ist friederike mayröcker
gewidmet und das von ernst jandl und
dann hat da musste ich heulen zu dem
gedicht ja und ich hatte nicht gewusst
dass das möglich ist das war eben diese
dieser moment wo ich
vollkommen
überwältigt war von nicht nur von dem
gefühl sondern eher von von der
erkenntnis dass sowas geht dass man
wirklich durch acht zeilen oder so
jemanden zu tränen rühren kann und auch
dass das den ganzen tag anhält dann
dieses gefühl von diesem gedicht von
diesem dann darin evozierten
weltbild und auch die doku die
wahrnehmung und da er dann
das habe ich dann immer wieder gesucht
und wollte das wahrscheinlich kann man
sagen bis heute möchte ich irgendwie
ähnliche und verwandte effekte immer
wieder erleben und auch selbst erzeugen
können ja so so hat das begonnen
natürlich ist sind solche linearen
herleitungen ein wenig verkürzt und
falsch aber so kann man es ganz gut
erzählen glaube ich auch dass andere gab
es denn andere dinge auf die du da in
deiner jugend rhein gekippt bist also
ich zum beispiel ab sehr sehr lange nur
sachbücher gelesen weil ich einfach
dinge wissen wollte und da hat mich
fiktion gar nicht so interessiert
hattest du irgend sowas was sich damals
umgetrieben hat somit 15 16 ja es war
manchmal habe ich tatsächlich das sagt
bücher gelesen am liebsten über
verschwörungstheorien
so ich glaube es kam eine ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher ist kommt von dem ex
files so dieser hype oder aktive erfolg
der serie und auch meiner wirklich bis
heute anhaltenden begeisterung für die
visuelle schönheit von ufo videos von so
amateuraufnahmen ich bin das wie kokons
also so richtig dass ganz harte jan van
helsing zeug ja ja genau das passiert
sind die so trübte sie denn den habe ich
das gelesen ja ja ja ich erinnere mich
an eine sehr gute phase
denn den haben auch andere weniger so
ganz in braun versprochen vermischte
aber sks werde es war ein
gefühl das man also geheimnisse und
okkulte lehrern da irgendwie studieren
kann was er nicht stimmt es ist ja
irgendwie nur die fantasiewelt von einem
menschen also aber das ist das machen
die eben das gibt's ja bis heute also
sind
wie heißt der david lage ist
diesen aber es gibt also
leute die halt so dokumentationen sowie
dokumentationen und bauen die so ähnlich
wirken wie dokumentationen aber
eigentlich ist es nur ihre
fantasiewelt irgendwelche mächtigen
familien und oder irgendwelche
illuminaten oder freie oder irgendwas
und ja ich hatte ich hatte schon ein
eintrag dass das non fiction ist aber
das ist es ja auch überhaupt nicht und
interessanterweise diese merkwürdige jan
van helsing hat dann auch romane
begonnen mal unter einem anderen namen
und die habe ich dann auch gelesen und
die waren wirklich so furchtbar schlecht
geschrieben dass ich das dann aufgehört
habe gott sei dank also erst dann durch
die schlechte pro sein gottseidank dann
irgendwann das ist etwas entschärft für
mich der red älter härter rein gekippten
auch sonst
ja ja gut dass es ernst jandl gab ich
habe ja da hat so habe ich noch eine
nachfrage dieser acht zeilen gelesen
oder gehört oder gesehen gelesen still
gelesen ja das sind das war wie sehr
wichtige unterscheidung auch weil ich
wäre vielleicht nicht so beeindruckt
gewesen wenn es ein video gewesen wer
von einer lesung weil so eine eine
beeindruckende rede ein eindruck hinter
monolog in einem film also sowas das
gibt es ja manchmal man sieht das ist ja
genau das das lustig dass das geht dass
man da im museum herz berührt werden
kann auch wenn es jetzt wenn man somit
sind mit zwölf forrest gump schaut oder
so dass man gut an so gerührt jetzt gibt
es ja manchmal so was ja aber
eben das still gelesen aber das
war ja ich vermute dass ich da auch
wirklich beeindruckt war von der
ökonomie der ein bisschen technisch
formuliert der datenübertragung es sind
wirklich nur auf einem papier und ich
schau still drauf und habe innerlich die
ungeheuerlichsten empfindungen also das
ist ja eine eine riesige
zuwachs an intensität der da passiert
und ein film ein kinofilm also sieben
mal
er wirkte auch sehr große wirkt größer
als man selber ein gedicht weg nicht
größer als man selber das klein zu
klappern weg pack bar ganz schnell und
ein film dauert an und und und übertönt
und über brüllt alles
da kann irgendwie 200 menschen die da im
kino sitzen mühelos in schach halten wie
sein ein dirigent der das ist von der
struktur her viel machtvoller und ein
gedicht ist was ganz ganz
dünnes nur hauchdünn auf einem papier
und kann's ausreißen kann so leicht
vernichten und dass das muss mich auch
glaube ich irgendwie auf seine
unbewusste weise beeindruckt haben
damals
und dann hast du angefangen eigentlich
gedichte zu schreiben also nicht mitteln
sehr dicken roman für die man sich ja
auch kennt sondern erst mal so mit der
kleinen form ja nur nur kleine farm nur
auch ich hatte eigentlich nicht
so sehr den also ich hatte weder die
konzentration noch den wunsch nach
erzählungen nach geschichten damals
wusste eigentlich gar nicht dass das was
anderes ist als eine film erzählung hat
eine serie oder so was so ein langes
buch das kam dann erst nach und nach das
muss man üben
meistens denke unser deutschlehrer hat
sich sicher redliche mühe gegeben dass
wir das irgendwie auch unternehmen und
versuchen aber ich wollte das dann nie
und hab dann erst so ja also meinem
zivildienst viel zu lesen begonnen und
da bin ich dann so
wirklich süchtig geworden nachlesen es
gibt also fünf stunden am tag bis spät
in die nacht oder ganz früh aufgestanden
das war dann wirklich seine sondern ein
neues ganz ganz intensiv verfolgt das
hobby und dazu dem neige ich sowieso
sehr also dass das ein hobby sehr
wichtig wird das morgen macht manche
nennen das berger spektrum oder etwas
also ich habe halt also so starke
partikularinteressen die wirklich hart
umkämpft werden auch von mir dann und
die sehr wichtig sind oft zu viel
vielleicht auch von normalem leben
verdrängen also ich habe das schon ganz
gut im griff jetzt aber neigt dazu und
das damals war das ziemlich unreguliert
glaube ich dass die begeisterung fürs
lesen
und dann ja dann will man glaub ich sage
immer man aber ich wollte dann offenbar
irgendwie diesen diese wohltat erwidern
die mir das so hundertfach
entgegengekommen ist dass es gibt ja so
viele bücher man sieht es ja dann auch
buchstäblich in buchhandlungen sind
seine übermacht und alle können das so
potentielle jedes könnte eines solches
seinem wohltat sein die einen verzaubert
und vollkommen sein neues leben schenkt
für fahrstunden und irgendwie habe ich
wollte ich das awi dann halt so dass das
dass das auch von mir aus strömen nicht
nur absorbiert wird so in einem endlosen
hunger aber hier so entsteht das
vielleicht bei allen der linie vor
manchmal bevor wir nach den
partikularinteressen nochmal genauer
fragen müssen wir natürlich einen
gebürtigen grazer dessen
erweckungserlebnis aus wien stammt
graz/wien frage stellen
graz ist für mich auch forum stadtpark
alfred kolleritsch manuskripte also eine
gruppe eine literarische gruppe eine
ausprägung die über graz hinaus
ausgestrahlt hat und
sich selbst vielleicht sogar noch
wichtiger gefunden hat als sie dann von
außen wahrgenommen wurde wie ist es
damit in der stadt aufzuwachsen fällt
das überhaupt auf nimmt man das war
nimmt man also diesen diesen avantgarde
impetus dieser stadt war auch mit dem
steirischen herbst und so dass er
einiges los oder schafft man das
aufzuwachsen und daran völlig vorbei zu
leben und trotzdem natur zu kommen aber
man wächst sehr stark damit auf also
zumindest immer auch wenn man sich nicht
so sehr dafür interessiert man man kennt
die namen und das sind dann so so also
lokale gottheiten und es also dass wenn
ihr und dann als ich begonnen habe auch
zu publizieren icht publizieren so jetzt
in büchern aber zur literatur
zeitschriften und vor allem lesungen zu
machen das war damals so kurz nach dem
jahr 2000 die beste möglichkeit das war
so vor blogs noch also dass und for
social media noch lange vorher
da merkt man schon dass dir der
vergleich immer sehr stark gekommen ist
und zwar lustigerweise was ich am
häufigsten gehört habe war er die jetzt
dazu auf lesebühnen und literatur
zeitschriften publiziert ihr seid
wirklich viel viel viel braver als die
klassiker das ist die klassiker wie die
die die
teilweise schon verstorbenen und
irgendwie so ein klassiker aus greifen
sollten im droschl verlag das war
vorhandenen
grazer gruppe dichter die waren viel
wilder als ihr was eine interessante in
version der üblichen literaturgeschichte
ist also weil das sonst immer die zu ist
wie die klassik wir haben also die
bisherige die anerkannte gilt nicht als
experimenteller wilder und unbequemer
als das als die neue generation ist
immer umgekehrt normalerweise und da da
erlebt man aber das so dass man
kritisiert wird für ihr seid nicht
provokant genug ihr seid auch überhaupt
nicht irgendwie
energiegeladen gedrückt dass das
wirklich es hat mich also hat mich
wütend gemacht immer und und aber es war
auch lustig es war also ist wirklich ein
die die absurdität dieses vorwurfs hatte
wirklich seinen humorvollen charme dann
so wenn man ein bisschen zurückdreht und
das betrachtet und eine interessante
paradoxien und dass das ein vermischung
geben kann von avantgarde und und
klassik oder von anerkannte also dass
eine avantgarde das anerkannte paradigma
das ist in graz ganz stark und dann habe
ich auch jahrelang vermieden die alle zu
lesen
dass das war ganz logisch also ich habe
mir gedacht die liste nicht irgendwie so
wolfgang bauer theaterstücke wenn wir
alles super finden was wird da schon
drin stehen großartig ist nicht oder
oder werner schwab und so weiter
der nicht jetzt so die grazer gruppe
wochen später in den einzigen und
natürlich wenn man das dann trotzdem mal
anschaut man so über seine vorurteile
spring sieht man was das für
fantastische autoren waren ja so
auch auf natürlich alfred kolleritsch
seine ist eine romane und also vor allem
die grüne seite
wirklich ein meisterwerk ganz
rätselhaftes buch und ich hätte ihn
wahrscheinlich
ganz früh nicht gern gelesen weil er als
man diese dieser dieser ja wie nennt man
das der vorsitzender der grazer
literatur war
ja es ist interessant wenn wenn es
einmal so eine eine formen sprengende
und und wirklich stark auch so denn den
bürger provozierende ab und gab und die
alle dann nach und nach berühmt werden
dass das bedeutet für die folgenden
generationen wenig wenig spielraum ich
glaube das hört auch die frankfurter
satire szene seit jahrzehnten also wir
haben hier ein condor so ein bisschen
also die titanic redaktion bekommt so
viele leserbriefe immer wieder von wegen
früher da war dir aber noch und so dass
es anscheinend in solchen sich eher als
avantgardistisch verstehenden
biotopen durchaus eine konstante
kann ich mir vorstellen ja ich glaube
ich dass und es gibt noch nicht ein
gutes vokabular darüber kommt mir vor es
auch in graz ist die
literaturwissenschaft nicht also mir ist
nichts aufgefallen dass wo dieses
phänomen so ein bisschen mal auch
vielleicht ebenso den vergleich zu so
was weder frankfurter satire literatur
wo das ein bisschen beleuchtet werden
würde jetzt ein gutes ab bisschen
akademisches thema das muss man jetzt
nicht so wichtig aber es ist schon
lustig wenn man das mal am eigenen leib
so erlebt oder am eigenen geistigen wenn
man so und den vorwurf bekommt du bist
so jung du kannst noch nicht produzieren
[Gelächter]
lernen erstmals 6 20 jahre das handwerk
so wird erst einmal ein meister so was
ja eigentlich also normalerweise nie so
funktioniert
das schöne ist dass die waren ja auch
dann wirklich provoziert durch unsere
lange weile lang langweiligkeit also bei
unser nicht provokantes und so ein
bisschen
vielleicht behutsames dichten waren die
vielleicht eben hinreichend provoziert
rafa ist
perfide
aber wir müssen noch mal auf das nischen
wissen und auf die abseitigen interessen
zu sprechen kommen oder das
enzyklopädische wie es glaube ich es in
der jury begründung
ich wusste ja wahnsinnig gerne du gibst
du ja immer so rein in diese in diese
seiten verästelungen dass der
kulturwissenschaft jetzt zuletzt eben
hast du dieses buch geschrieben die
bienen und das unsichtbare über plan
sprachen schon jetzt nicht das
hauptthema der sprachwissenschaft es ist
schon ein interessanter seiten 2
manchmal frage ich mich sammelst du das
gezielt also früher hätte man
wahrscheinlich hingesetzt und hätte mit
der nagelschere artikel ausgeschnitten
oder aus wissenschaftlichen journalen
oder sowas oder ist das wirklich so ein
ich lasse mich durchs internet treiben
und klicke mich nächtelang durch die
wikipedia und wie es denn da so denn
dann lese und dein sammle verhalten
ja das hat begonnen interessanterweise
mit facebook das war zwar vorher schon
da aber das ist mitgeteilt habe war
tatsächlich da dieses ehrte die meine
erste sozialen medien
ja sucht kann man sagen ich bin jetzt
nimmer auf facebook schon lang nicht
mehr aber damals
so 2009 war das gericht habe ich
begonnen und dann habe ich jeden tag ein
fundstück hinauf getan von irgendwo sich
ein roboter der irgendwann gebaut wurde
und com kann dies und das oder irgend
jemand der eine anekdote bei einem mann
der den zylinderhut erfunden hat und
deswegen rechts ausgelöst hat in den
straßen von london oder ihr irgendetwas
so aus also
ja ich habe super spiel so bücher gern
wo jemand irgendwo ein ganz ganz
unwichtigen aspekt von sich ein dickens
roman auf 300 seiten betrachtet so wie
zb welche welche art von straßenkehrer
gab es damals und welche welchen meint
dickens wenn er sagt straßenkehrer und
will also so ganz ganz sagen also eine
suchbewegung in einen unwichtige eine
wichtige fragestellung hinein die aber
dann nicht unwichtig bleibt sondern auch
meistens wirklich so ungeheure
reichtümer enthält dass das war damals
so main
so habe ich mein lesegenuss organisiert
meistens und dann war gab es da zum
ersten mal eine möglichkeit das an
freunde mitzuteilen jeden tag ohne
ohne dem ganzen eine ouvertüre oder ein
hör mal zu oder hey schau mal ich hab
das geht das entdeckt sondern man kann
jetzt einfach hin schreiben und das war
erlaubt und das man muss das nicht ins
gespräch einstreuen aktiv das war der
vorteil von diesem facebook damals und
da habe ich dann bemerkt dass das auch
eine literarische form sein kann nämlich
so das fundstück großer gedicht das
kennt man ja auch jetzt machen wir viele
und also zu einfach die dass das
schildern einer einer leuchtenden
begebenheit oder eines dns details oder
irgend einer interessanten kombination
zweier dinge oder auf etwas was vor
absurdität so so schön strahlt und ein
auch so ein bisschen wie die
ja eine so versöhnt mit der menschheit
in weil es so bizarre und das turnier
hat das habe da jeden tag und dann
kriegt man hat likes und wird dann so
süchtig und dann streitet man sich dann
jahrelang und auch auf facebook und dann
irgendwann auch mal genug oder wie der
sarg wieder man aber ich hatte dann
genug davon
da noch irgendwas vorgeworfen bekommen
von fremden und dann ja jetzt bin ich
aber immer noch auf social media ist ja
nicht zu ende aber bei twitter geht es
viel besser
da da brauche ich nicht da bin dass wir
das produkt ist ist etwas
passt besser zu mir und ich habe
wahrscheinlich größere mühe mir dass
dereinst an abzugewöhnen
diese fundstücke die klingen so ein
bisschen ab asyl haft
und und vereinzelt und
ich krieg das noch nicht so ganz mit dem
mit denen mit ihm zusammen also von
partikularinteressen genannt das mach
ich da wirklich rein stürzt oder hobby
oder so also das interesse kann ja auch
so aussehen dass habe das dass man zum
beispiel
ja alles über
es wird jetzt klingt bisschen albern
aber jetzt habe ich wirklich mal gemacht
ich wollte einmal zum beispiel alles
sammeln wo was mit händen zu tun hat
also einen eine hand von einem menschen
eine hand die irgendwas in der
weltgeschichte ungewöhnliches eine
abgetrennte hand oder eine hand die sich
irgendwie
schwer zu es klingt jetzt so komplett
absurd aber ist so funktioniert das mag
man das ist also hat sein leitmotiv und
dann sammle ich das jetzt also wie das
technisch machen es ist dann schon
meistens dateien oder nur ein dienst
bücher und meistens sind die nicht
wirklich gut kommunizierbar also dass
das ist dann wirklich so ein hobby und
das ist ja auch dann egal sozusagen
spielt keine rolle im sozialen leben wo
es eine rolle zu spielen beginnt ist
wenn es wenn man wenn sich diese story
teller fühler auf regeln und man denkt
hat es ist eine geschichte das kann man
doch erzählt das ist ja dass das ist ein
buch zum beispiel und so hat die dass
bei diesem
hat diese idee
diese faszination für gedichte
entsprachen die niemand lesen kann das
sei einerseits ist das was was lustige
das ist es ist was ja es ist etwas
witziges dass das existiert oder sagte
irgendwie irritiert auch manchmal wird
er in gebieten wenn man darüber
nachdenkt warum macht es jemand der
schreibt findet eine sprache und schreib
dann in kindlichen trainer ist doch
unfair weil vielleicht war das gedicht
schön und wir müssen jetzt die sprache
lernen erst das ist einfach nur gemein
und dann
fällt das immer wieder auf dann lernt
man was sinn plan sprachen wird warum
finden sich manche menschen sprachen was
für verschiedene geschichten gibt es da
und dann nach und nach
das kam vielleicht erst eben mit der
erfahrung einige bücher geschrieben zu
haben war dann dieses dieses gefühl das
ist eine story das funktioniert als als
als novelle fast oder als non fiction
roman kurzroman soja und
vielleicht auch mit der erlaubnis die
einen manche andere
es gibt noch mal so werke die man die
oder möglich gibt werke die schon
gelesen habe einige male und die dann
seine eine verzögerte einen einfluss so
auf mich haben also und das sieht so aus
dass man dann seine erlaubnis spürt also
einen rückenwind das darfst du das ist
dass das geht dass das darfst du dir das
dach zu probieren so und vielleicht wird
es bei dem buch über die plan sprachen
die bücher von dem
mit ganz sympathischen glaube ich als
mensch aber doch irgendwie
eindrucksvollen non fiction erzähler im
manual cara der gibt da gibt es einige
so biografische bücher von ihm und auch
bücher über über die frühe christliche
kirche rolle um das königreich als reich
gottes auf deutsch carrick und das habe
mir gedacht dass ich hatte das
kleinkastell sowas auch probieren sowas
in der art
science fiction roman und sachbuch aber
da ist erzählt wie ein roman und wie
macht man das dann ist das dann
technisch wieder schwieriger interessant
aber
also verschiedenen dingen kommt das dann
zusammen vielleicht das zusammenzufassen
als
nötiges partikularinteressen ich glaube
ich auch nur nach was über mich gesagt
wird und das hat vielleicht gar nicht
wirklich so tief mit mir zu tun das wort
nerd wird häufig gesagt und ich
wiederhole es manchmal mürrisch manchmal
irgendwie um interessant zu klingen
glaube nicht dass es jetzt wirklich viel
bedeutet so ähnlich wie
das was ich wörter wie
eine deskriptive hört dafür eine person
meistens irgendwie so
ein paar ein paar punkten irgendwie
bisschen anhaften und rest ist eine
imaginierte übereinstimmung
eine selbstbeschreibung die du gerade
verwendet hast du würde ich gern kurzem
noch aufgreifen und da wüsste ich gerne
mehr darüber nämlich so sagt es manchmal
notiert man dann was findet was und dann
richten sich die story teller oder
storytelling fühler auf
das ist so der moment in dem man merkt
dass da könnte was entstehen wie wie ist
das genau
sind diese schüler gewachsen waren die
immer schon da wann hast du sie das
erste mal gefühlt dass du diese
sinnesorgane besitzt wie stellt man sich
schwierig also schwierig zu sagen ich
esse waren sicher nicht immer da ich
hätte wirklich lange zeit keine keine
schüler in der hinsicht aber
geschichten sind
lustigerweise so dass sie wirklich sehr
häufig die und sehr deutlich
wiedererkennbare formeln verwenden oder
phasen oder
sachen die also elemente des sind sind
immer dieselben ja es ist acht typische
bausteine und die sind häufig ganz ganz
sklavisch befolgt und trotzdem springen
sie uns dann immer so neu und so
überwältigend und überraschend an die
diese bisschen paradoxe doppel gestalt
von
erzählungen oder von geschichten die
kenne ich es nirgends sonst in keinem
anderen medium das ist nicht es gibt
nichts in der musik das so wäre
vielleicht mehr vielleicht weiß
vielleicht ist in der musik was
ähnliches durch die durch die die die
tonarten und das soll irgendwie immer
wieder dieselben sind aber
er jedenfalls daher springt mir immer so
an dieses dieses diese komische
bis ein bisschen widersprüchliche
gestalt und was das dieses aufbringen
dass der toy story teller führer ist ist
wahrscheinlich ein anspringen auf die
archetypen formen oder auf das was man
als zum beispiel dass es nun liest eine
geschichte und oder man liest eine seine
irgendeine recherchierte biografie und
merkt da gibt es einen ruf zum abenteuer
da wird jemand gegen seinen willen in
eine in ein kampf in ein abenteuer in
eine suchbewegung oder in einer in einen
rettungsversuch oder in ein irgend etwas
dramatisches hineingezogen erst weigerte
sich und dann
wird in ihm etwas über stimmt oder ist
eine wahre natur meldet sich oder irgend
sowas ja das gibt es ja manchmal inso
geschichten und das ist so ein eine
erste es ein element in ganz vielen
erzählungen fast allen dramatischen
erzählungen die
die irgendwie ein problem und dessen
lösung zu zum inhalt haben da kommt das
vor oder es gibt etwas man liest etwas
wo jemand an einem ideal
etwas opfert und schaden anrichtet für
eine idee dann ist diese archetypische
sache dass das also die innenwelt passt
nicht mit der außenwelt über ein und
wenn das extrem zugespitzt wird hat man
sofort sein aber ich habe dann sofort
sein eine auf leuchtende wolke an
parallel geschichten im kopf also da da
gibt es ganz viele so ähnliche die aber
jetzt also die die sich das so als diddy
diddy tragischen geschwister dieses
dieser recherchierte biografie momente
melden und ja so dass es eigentlich
recht genussvoll auch in der aber man
kann es nicht gut teil man kann es erst
dann teilen wenn man das handwerklich
und nicht nur handwerklich sondern auch
irgendwie
auch mit mitmenschlich
wertvoll macht oder werden erst schwer
zu sagen dass so dass es auch wirklich
für andere menschen von bedeutung ist
das funktioniert meistens so dass man
halt das mit sich selber in resonanz
acker des feuers auf das ist so
abstraktes wog noch mal nach also das
ist ja auch mal weise ungefähr was ich
meine ist er ist jetzt aber also mein
geschichte erzählt man nicht nur indem
man die pdi die recherchierten fakten ab
erzählt oder dass das imaginierte
einfach gerichtet sondern das so dass es
ihn in einer resonanz tritt mit anderen
bewusstsein und das geht über sprache
das geht über so etwas wo auch
lebenserfahrung irgendwie auf
gespeichert ist es geht um dinge die
also dieses dieses dieses wiedererkennen
von naso so ist das leben stimmt das ist
so ja also diese diese dinge und da oder
auch so kann man das auch sehen oder
soja
glaubt dass das kann man ja unendlich
verfeinern auch bis bis innenbereich der
buchstaben sogar manchmal was ich
übrigens auf twitter gelernt habe auch
das gibt dass der einzelne buchstabe auf
ca durch diese falsch reibung der
twitter sprache manchmal habe ich
gelernt dass selbst auf der ebene geht
es
ich muss unbedingt noch mal auf twitter
zu sprechen kommen ich habe mal mit
sascha stanicic darüber gesprochen und
er meinte also twitter ist für ihn so
eine art testgelände also ihr beide seid
ihr glaube ich so im deutschsprachigen
raum so schauen die aktiveren autoren
die das auch wirklich als als etwas
nutzen und bei ihm war es ja wirklich so
dass der roman herkunft der dann auch
die buchpreis bekommen hat ist
eigentlich als twitter fred entstanden
und wurde von da ab immer weiter
ausgebaut
aber du nutzt das ja schon ein bisschen
anders weniger erzählend er so feeling
für die kleineren formen habe ich das
gefühl
was was machst du da was ist das für
dich ist dass diese radikale
zeitgenossenschaft von der die jury
spricht oder ist es vielleicht was ganz
anderes
bei mir hat es begonnen durch wieder
ähnlich wie überhaupt immer im leben
durchlesen also es war zuerst dass das
begeisterte lesen ich war zuerst ein
zwei jahre passiv auf twitter ohne eine
irgendwas zu schreiben und das war so
2015/16 da haben dann treffen die ersten
twitter poeten poet ihnen begonnen zu
schreiben die waren nicht so wie zum
beispiel ich dann oder sascha stanicic
oder sibylle berg oder sehen die die die
auch bücher schreiben und hauptsächlich
bücher schreiben und in der welt mit
beiden beinen stehen und dann halt
twitter ist so eine interessante
wie es nennt das testgelände oder eine
spielwiese oder eine simulation soder
oder auch nur etwas wo dinge geboren
werden sondern es ist ihre haupt
ausdrucksweise es ist das einzige so wie
zum beispiel
jemand wie die
momentan mein lieblings account der
computer fan 2001 der schon recht lange
schreibt dass es wirklich eine eine ganz
innovative neue form von dichtung auch
ein riesiges ungeheures werk was diese
person war immer sie sein mag da
geschaffen hat man könnte das natürlich
jetzt in einem buch welt ziehen und ich
hoffe es wird getan weil bücher leben
länger als webseiten aber es hat nicht
es strahlt nicht dahin aus es ist nicht
für die buch weil es nicht im dienst das
ist nicht ein ausgelagertes tagebuch es
ist da darf da passiert die dichtung und
das habe ich da wahrgenommen und tritt
oder genossen und einfach über besoffen
dazu ganzes jahr davon aber dann auch so
im alltag schon zu sprechen begonnen wie
die werden oft so diese diese
beschreibungen und diese formeln dies
ergibt und habe dann erst dadurch
begonnen selber mehr zu twittern und
mehr dazu schreiben und die heute ist es
eigentlich für mich
halt es ist nicht etwas was zufällig auf
twitter passiert sondern es ist halt das
was darf was da geht dagegen gedichte
dagegen
tweets oder wie man das nennen will
beobachtungen klein also
und dass das spiel ganz anders ich würde
auch keine gedichte mehr in büchern
veröffentlichen wollen weil die nicht
gelesen werden das kind jetzt auch so
ein bisschen blöd aber man kriegt die
bücherpreise und sagt wir würden nicht
gelesen das kind so kokett larmoyant
aber ich meinte mein das auch so ein
bisschen prinzipiell also gedichtbände
sind eine sehr kleine sehr
versteckte form sie haben spielen gar
keine rolle mehr kulturell und sie sind
sie haben es sehr schwer sowie das
gedruckte theaterstück hat es sehr
schwer es wird nicht offenbar nicht gern
gekauft darum finde ich es auch nicht
schade ist ein gedichte oder poetische
kurze sachen in eine form zu bringen wo
sie gelesen werden gut man kriegt dann
kein geld dafür macht ja nix ist nicht
so schlimm hat man ja für gedichtbände
auch nicht unbedingt viel bekommen
vorher außer man ist so einer von zwei
menschen im deutschen sprachen sie den
wagen oder so der angeblich dabei sind
50.000 stück verkauft um seine gedichte
aber sonst heißt das also dass aus dem
volk halt nichts aus dieser einen
ausnahme und ja ich verwende twitter
eigentlich so wie ich vielleicht in
einer twitter losen welt gedichtbände
und
flugblätter oder sowas hat verteilte
zettel verwenden würde und
genau das ist das um die frage ob das
nicht irgendwo anders abdrucken also
vielleicht gelegentlich
vielleicht macht man hier und da aber
ich ja ich finde es lebt da und lebt
halt da kurz und kann auch gelöscht
werden ich brauche nur irgendein blöde
bemerkung machen vielleicht eine sehr
fein geworden in den letzten jahren sehr
cancel ängstlich und dann ist man
natürlich gelöscht es kann schnell
passieren und weil ich glaube diese
mechanismen diese algorithmen die
meldungen die man da provozieren kann
sind sehr trigger happy in einigen
letzten zeit und ja dann dann ist das
alles weg also das bin ich mir auch
bewusst und speichert es auch nicht
jetzt groß aber vielleicht macht mir das
auch irgendwie vielleicht heißen schwer
zu sagen weil vielleicht hat es auch
seinen charme für mich dass es so auf
sand gebaut ist dass es so schnell
wieder versinken wird wenn ich glaube
niemand denkt dass twitter in zehn
jahren genauso aussieht oder genauso
vorhanden ist dass die die archive da
durchsuchbar werden oder so das ist ja
heute schon auch schwer zu finden also
eine eine eine eher transiente
vorübergehende
vergänglich kann man ein bisschen so
politik sagen sein vergängliche form ja
und da da fühle ich mich ganz gut also
dass das schöne an twitter ist wirklich
so ein bisschen das dass das was jetzt
letztes jahr war nicht so leicht zu
finden ist auch und oder man muss dann
schon extra suchen mit zur datums suche
ja
hoffentlich war das eine kompetente
antwort
ja und das war
ich auch unsere pläne die er verblüffend
nah ist an dem was du über das jandl
gedicht am anfang gesagt hast über diese
acht zeilen die ganz zart sind und nur
auf sowie ein dünnes papier das man
rausreißen kann das dann irgendwie auch
verschwinden kann das weg sein kann und
so weiter also da hast du ja
am anfang deines lebens etwas gefunden
und erlebt was jetzt in dieser
prekären twitter situation auf eine
bestimmte weise auch enthalten ist es
stimmt ja ich habe das nie gedacht aber
es stimmt ja die diese
das macht vielleicht ist das ein
feind von mir ganz
beherzt umkämpft so eine kostbarkeit das
ist das immer geben muss bei mir so ein
so eine kleine ganzjahr vergänglich
zarte sache über die man dann sich ewig
freut oder so ja das kann sein
vielleicht bedeutet es mir deswegen so
vielleicht projiziere ist auch bisschen
hinein das kann sein
dass fast das blut bei oft ist es ja gar
nicht so vergänglich wie man ja sieht
bei leuten die in keine dummheit gesagt
haben vor sieben jahren mal dann die
hängt ihnen plötzlich ewig nach die
würden sich wünschen so eine gewisse
fähigkeit der das sind die arosa ist
sony verzeiht ja genau jetzt gibt oder
auch zum beispiel dass sie billig das
jetzt zu bringen aber es ist halt auch
hier überall der österreichische nicht
mehr bundeskanzler würde sich ja auch
wenn wünschen dass datenbestände
verschwinden würden und wenn ich dann
auch in den sinn leider nicht
verschwunden und wir können sie immer
noch lesen obwohl sie so unabsichtlich
und herrisch gelöscht wurden davon der
thomas schmid und
leider ist dann doch nichts für immer
gelöscht und das ist witzig auch dieses
dass es im fall einer razzia oder einer
einer nachbearbeitung durch
festplatten experten dass das trotzdem
alles noch da sein kann und zugleich
aber auch dann sie einem selber
plötzlich so schnell aberkannt werden
kann durch durch löschen des accounts
auch seine interessante doppel gestalt
sowie zwei extreme zugleich existieren
irgendwie die die wirklichkeit oder die
gegenwart und jetzt die die beginnenden
20er jahre das des 21 jetzt scheinen wir
von solchen komischen
extremen die sowohl die beiden so weit
so was diese paradoxen top doppel
zuständig die scheinen sich zu häufen
und die ja machen mich auch irgendwie
ganz konfus auch immer
mache also alltagsphilosophie mit
aber ich glaube diese diese doppel
zustände sind etwas wo ich schon das
gefühl habe dass ich die auch bei dir
und deinen büchern deiner gedankenwelt
schon irgendwie finde also so zum
beispiel dieses diese ständige
balancieren irgendwie zwischen realität
und fantastik was ich nie richtig
festlegt eigentlich und also ich habe
jetzt gerade die stunde zwischen frau
und gitarre gelesen und da kommt miss
bevor das ist so ein bisschen als ob die
realität irgendwie die bildstörung hat
als ob sie irgendwie zwischen den an den
rändern ausfranst nicht die eine welt
die andere sondern es ist ja auch
wirklich so ein so ein zwischending
also fand ich total interessant und
vielleicht ist das ja auch irgendwas was
was dein denken oder dein schreiben oder
das klingt jetzt mal so groß aber
vielleicht macht es tatsächlich dass
außer dass das was sich da so
interessiert dieses das kann sein
so paradox
motivation ist immer das womit eine
geschichte beginnt weiß auch warum tut
die person das war wenig wie kann man
auf die idee kommen also das ist eher
das canvas vorgestelltes sein oder
oder etwas recherchiert dass wir einfach
umschreibt ihm ein gedicht in einer
sprache die niemand lesen kann und
will dann alle bekehren dazu dass man
dass sie die sprache oder warum also in
dem roman die stunde zwischen franke dar
warum besucht jemand den den menschen
der für den tod seiner frau
verantwortlich war angeblich als stalker
warum besucht er den ständig in diesem
pflegeheim und geht dann mit ihm
spazieren was ist das ist das irgendwie
seine
also wiedergutmachung oder willen daran
dass ich will er den quälen wenn ja
warum ist merkt man ist ihm nicht an was
tut dieser mensch warum handelte er so
dass das immer so eine eine paradox oder
hineinzoomen in eine n ein mysterium ich
sage immer das wort ministerium gern
weil es so schön allgemein klingt und es
aber ich meine es wahrscheinlich auch
ganz
meins auch dann so richtig ernst also
das mysterium das des menschen so für
papa pathetisch trotzdem ich glaube das
pathos bewohner nicht ganz aufrecht und
schamlos ein bisschen sollte und ich mir
zum beispiel
jetzt diese koitka rohners sodass jahr
oder eineinhalb jahre was mir ganz viele
leute schon und was auch müssen wir
viele leute erzählt haben und was auch
mein eindruck war ist dass man zu gleich
zwei zustände im kopf hatte nämlich
man hatte das gefühl das ist eine echte
bedrohung das ist eine reale bedrohliche
gefährliche krankheit und zugleich ohne
dass das gelöscht wird von dem zweiten
hatte man das gefühl das wird aber
übertrieben
also ich denke dass das stimmt dass das
aber man hat die sind doppel eindruck es
wird medial viel zu sehr übertrieben und
zugleich ist es eine echte reale
bedrohung und danach schien anderes
manchmal sogar so dass die reale
bedrohung so hoch erschienen das die
mediale bericht statt um untertrieben
war das heißt es waren ist waren ein
dreifach paradox system
es war es war wirklich ist und das hält
jetzt ist nicht neu es hat das hat sich
schon wieder jetzt gelegt kommt mir vor
ein bisschen aber der zustand ist so
häufig beschrieben worden und er war
auch im meer und das ist so eine sache
die mich normalerweise dann auch reizen
würde zum zum schreiben das ist jetzt
aber noch viel zu frisch und zu
unübersichtlich und so umkämpft und zu
wir sagen wir sagen ja
vermint oder aber auch na ja gar nichts
es ist einfach zu verwirrend nacht ich
kann könnte darüber nichts schreiben
noch also außer tagebuch oder so man
halt irgendwie die momentane verwirrung
festhält aber ja solche doppel doppel
und auch noch mal dreifach paradoxen
dinge in motivationen warum macht jemand
was das ist für mich immer die fast in
jedem buch und jeder geschichte die der
grund warum ich dann das überhaupt
begonnen habe das kann man wirklich so
sagen
wenn es gesellschaftspolitisch oder oder
so weltpolitische dinge sind kann sein
dass sie dann nie irgendwas schreiben
kann darüber weiß mir zu groß zu
unübersichtlich
zu
also ist wirklich auch verwandeln in so
einer
sein megafon halter vielleicht und das
weiß nicht ich kann bin ich gut mit
megafon in der hand
gehabt hat er einen ähnlichen eindruck
eigentlich also von dass das irgendwie
ist man das gefühl hat es ist zugleich
eine bedrohung aber zugleich wird man
irgendwie auch dazu gebracht also man
ist man es selbst klug genug das
einzuschätzen und es zugleich nicht klug
genug das recht zu schützen es ist
irgendwie menschen zuhören
gefahren realistisch einschätzen das
glaube ich echt keine menschliche
kernkompetenz habe ich das gefühl habe
vor menschen angst haben wofür menschen
nicht an angst haben ist glaube ich
nicht sehr rational ja
also ich glaube es tatsächlich nicht
weil
aber man hat ja dann doch vor etwas
angst und das ist dann das hat man dann
als festgelegtes ding und das muss
wahrscheinlich immer dann in der in
widerspruch stehen zu der
die art wie es erzählt wird ja oder die
art wie andere menschen darüber sprechen
das kannst du eigentlich beschreibt
vielleicht ein totaler binsenweisheit ja
aber das war ist mir ist schon so oft
gesagt worden dass sie mir gedacht habe
aha interessant
ich fasse es auch wahnsinnig schwer zu
verstehen aber ich hatte dann
tatsächlich eher weniger angst dass ich
das jetzt selber kriege und selber
irgendwie in der intensivstation lande
ich hatte eigentlich eher angst davor
dass ich jemanden wehrlosen anstecke
dann schuld daran bin dass der irgendwie
das ich weiß nicht meine eltern sind
irgendwie schon alt und so und man hat
dann vielleicht doch irgendwie leute im
in seinem umfeld wo man denkt so ich
müsste die ich muss gucken dass ich die
schütze
aber ohne da
bin ich habe keine ahnung gefangen und
wohl auch noch was in zeitungen steht
aber dann zum beispiel gerade das was
man aber man das hat sie auch ganz stark
habe immer noch auch so dass man
schützen möchte okay das ja auch etwas
gutes und niemand sollte einen das
irgendwie
kaputt schütteln diese diese diese diese
bereitschaft und dieses diese
standardeinstellung der fürsorglichen
und dann kriegt man so zum beispiel als
die impfungen zuerst mal vorgestellt
worden haben die immer dazu gesagt das
schützt nicht vor übertragung das
schützt nur vor die erste generation
dieser m rna viren schützen davor dass
man selber schwer krank und dann bekommt
man die informanten hatten aber immer
noch in sich diese nehmen dass er
eigentlich damit ich niemanden anstecken
und
dafür ist sie noch nicht dafür ist dass
nur aber eben welches eigentlich
deswegen so gern weil ich bin ich bin ja
bereit das opfer zu machen und so da und
das war's das war schon vor während das
war wirklich also wenn das sich jemand
wirklich bewusst ausgedacht hat ist das
eine eine echte
die größte verwirrung die bisher so
erlebt habe
wenn man's dann kühl und hinterher
betrachtet
sollst du krank werden ein brauchst
antikörper ja dann ist die entscheidung
nicht mehr so schwer aber so dieses für
andere handeln war in diesem coroner
dieser corona phase wirklich total
verwirrend und ich glaube nicht dass sie
so sein hätte müssten man hätte es doch
einfach besser kommunizieren können
wahrscheinlich aber ist diese diese
merkwürdige paradoxen doppel ding also
eigentlich nehmen das um zu schützen
auch das kann sie ja gar nicht einige
trotzdem um sich
und das ist so dass das hätte man ja ich
glaube es hat vielleicht wirklich da
einfach
pädagogisch klügere entscheidungen wie
etwa eiskanal ist aber hat ja niemand
etwas davon dass ich jetzt besser bei
sind ja da irgendwas aber ja aber
trotzdem so solche solche dinge
motivieren mich auch doch wirklich immer
abgesehen jetzt ganz europa oder darüber
schreibe nichts aber
zum zum hineinzoomen weil es meistens
das schöne dabei entsteht der effekt
entsteht dass die
die suchbewegung unendlich bleibt und
ganz
unerwartete bereiche aufhält und und
erleichtert dass das ist die schöne
sache dass das das geht zum beispiel
selbst in science fiction szenario wie
in meinem roman indigo da gibt's dann
ist eine super idee wo also kinder am
seine krankheit und dann muss man einmal
auf distanz bleiben zu denen und sonst
die wären nicht krank hat man selber
wird krank wenn man in die nähe kommt
das kann es ja nicht geben aber es ist
trotzdem man so eine sache die es da
gibt und die dann will die hauptfigur
rausfinden warum was was hat es mit dem
aussicht so ganz klassische so detektiv
motivation der betrachter so hinein
gezogen hat dann löst dann ein paar
kleine rätsel aber das große rätsel wird
immer unfassbarer immer schwieriger zu
zu haben oder zu sehen und es leuchtet
dann seinen
schiffs unterbauch der wirklichkeit aus
in so einer ist ein unheimliches
substrat aus dem alles da offenbar gibt
gekommen ist und dass das finde ich also
irgendwie sehr
häufig sagen wir sagen das bin ich jetzt
sehr stark zu dieser art von geschichte
wurde eine suchbewegung eine recherche
oder ein einlösen wollen und dann merkt
man es ist unmöglich man sieht aber
kurze zeit das universum so
aufblitzenden in diesen in diesen
und zusammenbau paaren
wissensbestände sind hat er vielleicht
sammelt
so esoterisch
diese dieser orte der der körperlichen
und geistigen hinfälligkeit das ist auch
etwas was ich immer wieder wiederholt
bei dir also es gibt ja auch in die
stunde zwischen frauen gitarre ist die
hauptfigur natalie in einem wohnheim für
behinderte menschen
klienten wie sie heißen dort in die
frequenzen spielt auch an alten flieger
und eine
psychotherapeutin eine rolle was
fasziniert dich an diesen orten so also
du hast wahrscheinlich zivildienst
gemacht hast so im dienst gemacht
aber das kann ja nicht alles sein also
irgendwas muss doch da noch darüber
hinausgehen ist es irgendwie wollte das
ist das großprojekt das clemens also
eigentlich irgendwie aus dem heiler aus
in die welt oder so
es war sicher das eindrucksvollste jahr
meines lebens
bislang dieses zivildienst ja weil da
die verwandlung so stark war von
menschen der ich vorher war menschen
denkt nachher war das war so dass so
viel passiert in dem einen jahr das war
wirklich ganz ganz woanders kann man
sagen und ich glaube so einem jahr merkt
man sich dann immer
und das ist ein unendlicher brunnen
jetzt für mich da kann immer immer
hineingehen und selbst das so dass die
erinnerung an die vergangenheit beginnt
fast immer da und vielleicht mache ich
dann deswegen dazu dass oxycyte
so lange romane da in so einer welt
spielen zu lassen sie es auch
interessant für mich weil sie eine
abgeschlossene welt ist also sagen ein
wohnheim ist eben
eine welt für sich mit eigenen regeln
und
habe in dem einen jahr hat hatte ich
zumindest den eindruck dass sie auch
etwas ein starkes gravitationszentrum
für die hat die eigentlich auch ein
leben außerhalb haben also die dann
trotzdem ein privatleben haben und da
nur arbeiten nicht jetzt da wohnen aber
da arbeiten selbst die wohnen eigentlich
nach einer gewissen zeit dann sehr stark
darin und übernachten freiwillig und im
büro also dass das hat so eine energie
wie eine klinik vielleicht ein bisschen
oder wie wie manche anderen berufe die
ich jetzt nicht so dass der erste
direkte beobachtung kenne
und also dass das interessiert mir immer
heißt ist ein komischer formen zu sagen
das interessiert mich was ich glaube
ich sehe darin vielleicht eine art von
mine ein leben das mir auch immer droht
also da diese so hinein kippen und nicht
mehr wegkommen von etwas ja dass das mag
sein ich hatte große mühe das eine jahr
dann
das als das zu ende ging und ich dann zu
studieren begonnen habe es war fast
unaufhaltbar roger wieder zurück da
gibt es auch dann später erzählt
bekommen von so leuten die beim militär
waren das die eigentlich dann so sich
bisschen geschämt haben es zuzugeben
dass sie da gern wieder noch länger
gewesen wären obwohl sie auch irgendwie
total froh waren dass jetzt endlich weg
waren von dem blöden drill und
herumrennen und nie schlafen dürfen und
schlechtes essen oder und so weiter sie
haben das spiel geschimpft darüber aber
sie waren irgendwie nicht froh dass
jetzt da plötzlich wieder in der schule
waren
also dieses die schule ist zu ende so
für die jetzt in österreich muss man
sagen so die männlichen jungen menschen
müssen dann halt ein jahr was anderes
tun als seien sie haben ein ärztliches
attest
es gibt sich das geändert hatte ich
damals war das also militär oder
zivildienst und
die
die haben dann diese dieses die schule
ist zu ende und jetzt beginnt etwas
neues und nach einem jahr geht aber für
viele dann studieren dann geht die
schule weiter auf dem milieu war ich da
war halt die die studenten sind und das
ist glaube ich eine das beleidigt
irgendwas in einem selber das empfindet
man da hat man merkt man immer aber ich
habe glaube ich und viele andere hatten
ein bisschen mühe das als weiteren
schritt in das erwachsensein
wahrzunehmen wenn es war schon gewachsen
ja es wird fühlt sich wie ein
rückschritt vielleicht deswegen
erscheint mir dieses eine jahr dann so
strahlend und hält wo ich da in dem heim
für menschen mit behinderungen und auch
also vor allem blinde und
mehrfachbehinderte menschen
das fällt mir vielleicht deswegen immer
wieder ein und es waren auch so so
wahnsinnig spannende
[Musik]
also sachen wie die heute die ich heute
die nie wieder so erlebt hab zb
ich hoffe sie sind meist kleine anekdote
erzählen aber das ist so lange ungeklärt
okay aber das ist wirklich dass ich habe
das auch vor kurzem ein zu erkennen ist
ein artikel beschreibt beschrieben wo
psychologie heute heißt das cover hat
mich gefragt was ist ein eindrucksvolles
lernerlebnis was sie mal hat und dass
man sofort das eingefallen vor 20 jahren
und 21 ist schon seit hält nichts
gelernt
das ist und das war so da war ein ich
war auch in den sommermonaten war ich
portier also da gibt gab es dann kein
sport ihr häuschen und der ist auf der
partie ist auch urlaub gegangen von dem
institut war und ich durfte dann hat
seine arbeit machen und das war
eigentlich recht eintönig man sitzt da
mit seiner thermoskanne und vielleicht
ein buch und wartet dass man irgendwie
angerufen wird oder dass leute durch die
durch das tor kommen und dann kam aber
ein alter blinder mann also dessen also
ich hatte gar keine augapfels waren ganz
so ins leere höhlen da kam jeden tag
dazu mir ganz langsam tastete sich sagen
seinem gelände also entlang und kam dann
zu mir in die indy portier kabine setzte
sich nieder und hat irgendwelche sätze
gesagt so sowie auf den boden 8 und
boden irgendwas dass er ganz und ich
habe versucht zu verstehen was er mir
sagen will ich habe gedacht der ist
offenbar schlechter schwer demenzkrank
oder ich habe versucht zu verstehen
wovon er redet und hab dann mit
geschrieben sogar ein bisschen habe er
seine sachen wiederholt hab gedacht ich
knacke diesen code was er mir sagt aber
was er eigentlich wollte das habe ich
dann erst am ende dieses sommers
verstanden ist eine parabel diese war er
hat einfach nur musik imitiert er wollte
musik heran er wollte dass ich das radio
einschalten war langweilig und er kam
einfach jeden tag radio hören ins
portier häuschen das war's das war das
rätsels lösung ich habe es nicht
verstanden
gibt es wirklich nicht eben nie das
radio eingeschaltet die vollidiot ja er
hat einfach nur sowas wie so oft dürfte
also eher so was hat er gemacht mit mit
wörtern mit wortfetzen dann konnte er
nichts sagen können sie bitte das radio
einschalten wenn ich glaube hatte ein
bisschen angst vor mir ich war ein
bisschen unheimlich wusste nicht wer ich
bin
den alten trott erkannte aber der wahl
ohne unerklärlicherweise weg und als der
alte portier wieder da war hatte
einmal gestanden und habe dann mit ihnen
geredet und habe dann gemerkt das radio
läuft und man hat dann ist mir erklärt
worden er kommt er kommt jeden tag und
dann dann dann hören wir radio und dann
waren wir in dem kreis ist er hat
einfach
rhythmische so sind so much music oder
irgendwas was man halt so
volksmusik radio sachen hört einfach
imitiert und ich hab das nicht kapiert
ich war einfach so da der der wie meter
aus seinem leben berichten oder sind so
fragmente
literarischer gucken ja ja ja genau das
was er es war diese vermessenheit des
hermeneutik ist ja das ist so
fragmentiert wie du weißt land von von
elliott ja das ist diese diese fragen an
die sprache eines zerstörten
bewusstseins nobler und orit errichten
sich ja ja die hatten sich da gewaltig
schon aufgerichtet und dann
und dann meinte er kann man bitte
einfach das radio anschalten warum ist
es jemanden still und sie hat es einfach
nicht und dann sowas sowas gab es
hundertfach wirklich glaube nicht
übertrieben es war immer wieder und
es ist sicher so dass die begegnung auch
mit menschen mit behinderungen
oft voll sind von sowas weil man eben
mit mit unendlichen ja sein bündel an
vorurteilen und an für sie sprechen und
ihnen das leben momentan kurz gestalten
wollen und sie verstehen wollen und so
mit diesem ganzen furchtbaren blödsinn
kommt man tritt man leider oft vor sie
hin und sie belehren dann meistens mit
der zeit es sei denn man ist ganz blöd
aber
als 18-jähriger war ich noch ein
bisschen euro euro plastischer oder
konnten kontinent kannte ich noch lernen
schneller vielleicht bin ich heute viel
starker und unbelehrbarer aber ja so was
gab es da eben ganz häufig und deswegen
erscheint mir das auch immer in meinen
tagträumen als die die wichtige phase
ich glaube es kommen wohl noch
wichtigere phasen aber bislang ist das
die wichtigste weil danach war nur
studium und halt das dann arbeiten als
autor und so und das war nach sehr
ereignislose jahre äußerlich hat nichts
erlebt so aber nur innerlich und ich
glaube das ist jetzt kurz dabei dass das
setzt sich ändert hoffentlich aber
bislang war es so
ich habe den
das buch bot hier mir ausgeliehen von
einer freundin und sie hat einen satz
unterstrichen und mit einem dicken jahr
in versalien und ausrufezeichen markiert
und dieser satz lautet bagger sind die
besseren dinosaurier und
das fand sie anscheinend sehr
bemerkenswert
ich finde das ganz interessant weil bei
dir in deinen büchern leben immer wieder
die gegenstände also man hat irgendwie
mitleid mit gegenständen sie tun was und
sie haben eigenschaften und sie sind
irgendwie
existieren so ein bisschen neben den
tieren her irgendwie wo kommt denn diese
diese liebe und wo kommt das mitleid mit
den gegenständen her
ich glaube das kommt
mir fällt das auch auf das ist das
stimmt ja also dass die die feier von
ungezählten also ich hatte sicher schon
als kind dass wir zum beispiel einen weg
ein verlorener handschuh das ist demnach
getraut habe und mir vorgestellt habe
jetzt hat allein zu haus auf der straße
liegt und dass ich auch selber traurig
ist da an animismus der es wird auch so
kindern auf dem asberger spektrum
nachgesagt dass sie das verstärkt hätten
also ich weiß nicht ob ich das habe hat
eine solche
diagnose irgendeinen sinn ergibt ich
glaube es ist seine kurz sprechweise
unserer epoche die nicht viel wert hat
wahrscheinlich aber trotzdem scheint das
vielleicht recht ist das irgendwie mir
so
neurologisch sogar plausibel vielleicht
verteidigt die die sache wie mitleid
irgendwie bisschen anders das kann so
einfach ist da etwas verrutscht schon
generell oder es ist einfach eine eine
immer wieder frisch und wirksam eine
jahr frisch und und auch
ist es altert lisa eine art von
mitteilung also wenn man
wenn man eine metapher so verwendet das
dass zum beispiel ein etwas ungezählt
das etwas will das nützt sich nicht so
schnell ab also eine rein strukturelle
metapher die sowas wie
ja sonst wie das ihre tränen waren wie
im wasserfall und hat man wasser mit
wasser verglichen und beide es ist nur
einfach das irgendwo wasser ist es macht
eigentlich nichts deutlicher dass
einfach nur tot und langweilig und man
man macht das bild unschärfer sogar
anstatt man was man nur gesagt hätte sie
weint oder so
aber wenn man einen vergleich macht wie
zb einem jahr ein handschuh man macht
die tür auf und liegt auf der straße ein
handschuh und ich habe glaube ich mal
irgendwo in der haltung eines
angespülten seestern dann ist das ein
einerseits scharf des bildes sieht das
was man weiß wie es ein seestern ist
auch eine um charakteristische haltung
für einen für einen handschuh also als
besonders
arg gespreizt und er hat man unterstellt
ihm eine eine eine jahr in die tragische
reise bis hierher angespülten er war
zuerst in seinem heimat element in der
dieser da irgendwie vertrocknet und
gestorben und hat so pade bis vor meiner
tür hierher geschafft also dass das
erzählt viel zu viel und das so
funktionieren auch manchmal wirklich
nennt man das gute metapher gute bilder
in romanen die viel zu viel erzählen
müsste alles gar nicht sein es ist also
ganz viel ungeziefer information man
nimmt das viel zu ernst also man man man
hat man hat
der blick ist also geht somit viel zu
sehr einen etwas aber das macht das dann
eben dass das verzaubert das bisschen
mehr und macht
ja sonst gibt es ja keinen grund warum
ein handschuh auf einer straße erwähnen
sollte in einer
geschichte die hinreichend spannend ist
braucht man den vielleicht gar nicht
aber wenn es wenn es nicht darum geht
dass eine geschichte einfach nur
spannend ist sondern eben dass man
vielleicht ein bisschen wohnen kann in
ihr für für paar stunden dann dann
braucht solche dinge vielleicht hätte
ich gegen eigentlich so zu einer
politik vorlesereihe
aber er also gut ich bin ja auch gut
werde auch gefragt warum warum machst du
das oder wo kommt das ja
ich und ich bin also ich unterstreichen
wir solche sätze auch selber immer in
büchern also eine auf in deutscher
sprache der das sehr gut kann ist peter
handke der der hat auch immer solche
psyche animistischen beobachtungen wo
ein ein gegenstand vielleicht lebendig
erscheint oder umgekehrt etwas
lebendiger ins fast noch das dass das
umgekehrte häufig dass etwas belebt es
wie etwas unbeliebtes wirkt so
interessant vielleicht zur verschiedene
temperamente neigen mal zu der 1 unsere
anderen
nabokov ist auch so jemand wär das so
ganz besessen macht so dass es ein fast
zu viel wird manchmal so in den späteren
romane und wo man dann wirklich alles
ist das eine auf dem boden lag eine
schachtel wie so tat als wäre sie ein
buch ist ein roman von eben darüber sehr
gut oder in der ecke schlief ein
spielball der muss auch nicht unbedingt
schlafen der kann ruhig liegen brauch
den gegner also er hat so etwas eine
über
ausdrückliche
animistische ist ein
general update der wirklichkeit aber ja
es kann natürlich so eine manier werden
aber ich finde an sich ist es so einer
der königs wege zu einem
zu einer nicht sich nie ab nutzenden
kommunikation ja es ist ja wenn man
nicht sicher ob das stimmt aber es
klingt jetzt ein gutes zu behaupten
ja es kann sich schon ab nützen sich
vielleicht jemand so metaphern sind ja
überhaupt was witziges so wie
diese kennen was eine platte cannings
heißen die diese formelhaften metaphern
in der isländischen dichtung oder die so
manche
skandinavischen dichtung die
modern dass das wort für das meer ist
das war wahl weg oder so irgendwie oder
das war viel blut ist schwert wasser und
st und der brachte es war so ganz
fasziniert von diesen cannings erkennen
guardia wie es die mehr zeit und die
weiß ich so wahnsinnig schlecht so
wahnsinnig schlecht funktionieren als
als poesie aber zugleich irgendwie auch
so was sowas ja
sie gehen dann irgendwie so in ihrem
unbestimmt so bis hin zu herzen sie sind
so sie bemühens ist ein bisschen camp
würden wir heute sagen so ganz falsch
niedlich aber sie haben sowas camp
kempters
der irgendwie auch wieder total gut
funktioniert und irgendwie lustig und
sexy oder irgendwie so auch seinen
eigenen seine eigene lebendigkeit noch
hat eben weil es so erkaltet und
formelhaft und schlecht ist also ja also
so finden sein feld wo ich endlos gern
darüber nachdenke sowie
oder auch wo ich geht's beispiele auch
sammler wie wieso also setzte und so
vergleiche etwas ist wie etwas anderes
ich habe gern wie vergleiche das dass
das kann ich bin ein mensch der wie
vergleiche das muss man aber auch können
die ebenso handlich meistens schief und
dann manche gehen wieder gut
wir sind da ganz nah dran an so einem
sinneswahrnehmung thema
über das ich mich gerade schon
selbst gefragt habe und die tolle
gelegenheit habe dich zu fragen clemens
synästhesie
also für mich als nicht so ein
ästhetiker
fügt sich dann einer wahrnehmung eine
zweite hinzu das wirkt ein sohn
ästhetiker selbst gar nicht so trennen
können wenn ich das richtig verstehe
bist du einer dhf worte verdienten sich
bei dir mit farben wie wie es das wenn
du schreibst ist
das eine sache für die du dich auf die
du dich konzentrieren muss darf die
mannschaft stellen muss die man auch
ausblenden kann jetzt sage ich man und
meinen du oder
etwas
was dich begleitet in deinem
kompletten leben
macht man nutzt man das versprechen
literatur höher es wird glaube ich
generell bedeutsamer gelesen als es ist
also dass die von leuten die das nicht
kennen ist einfach so man hat eben viele
politiker haben
irgendein sinnes kanal der
interessanterweise mit einem anderen
verbunden ist fertig die gründe dafür
sind rein neurologisch und gar nicht
irgendwie
bedeutsam also aus einer aus
lebenserfahrungen oder aus aufgrund von
von gelernter philosophie oder sowas
kommt kann kommt nicht das ist kann
selber davon ganz frühen kindheit
meistens und bei mir ist es mit zahlen
und farben silben und und abstrakten
gesten und farben und manches
musikalische hat auch
taktil und farbe zugleich also ich mir
was du isst roth
fühlt sich fühlt sich auf dem handrücken
an und c dur ist so grasgrün und fühlt
sich so in der handinnenfläche also ganz
komisch warum es das macht und ich habe
gar kein gutes gehör sich nicht wirklich
absoluter man bald schon manchmal heißt
das ist eindeutig c dur und machen auch
nicht essen woran das widerlegt aber
trotzdem ist das ist einfach das
leuchtet halt nebeneinander auf selben
gehirn jetzt wenn man das aber hat
stellt man fest dass es eine so eine
grundsätzliche komik gibt nämlich in der
mitteilung dieser sache wenn man das
mitteilt erzählt man von einer welt die
niemand kennen kann und niemand auch
nach es nachempfinden kann es ist eine
per definition
erfahrbare welt und unerfahrene sache
man kann sie beschreiben abstrakt aber
selbst wenn man sie einem anderen sinne
ästhetik hervor ersetzt sagte er für
mich ist aber das was weiß ich die die
sieben nicht gelb sondern blau und und
man kann auch nichts damit anfangen und
besonders entzückend sind so anekdoten
ich glaube es ist super franz liszt ich
glaube es ist jetzt aber ich will man
jetzt sicher in ein berühmter komponist
soll gesagt haben
schon im hohen alter
zu einem konzert zu einem orchester sie
möchten bitte ein bisschen blauer
spielen an der stelle und die hätte erst
da gemerkt dass nicht alle menschen
dieses dieses dieser tonart oder diesen
akkord als blau empfinden es wird glaube
ich über das caribbean erzählt und über
über
drei sind jetzt auch erfunden aber
dieses spät erst bemerkten dass andere
menschen nicht dasselbe im körper im
kopf haben und dass man es auch nicht
ein innen erzeugen kann das ist das eine
ein unüberwindbares kontinuum gibt in
einem bereich der das stachel glaube ich
besonders dazu an dass man dann in den
bereichen wo es geht wo sie eine
überwindung des des kontinuums möglich
ist eine interpersonelle sein sein
übereinstimmung das machst ab besonders
begeistert verfolgt nämlich nie wie
krieg ich das bild das ich habe zu dir
ja das wie wie können wir das
überbrücken dass jemand
also das gefühl dass getrennt science
dieses nennt man das prinzip die um
individuation ist glaube ich mir das in
der philosophie bei schopenhauer das ist
dieses wir sind eine sache wissens eine
glühbirne und wenn die einriss erhält
sind wir tot und wir können uns nicht
vereinigen was auch nicht ganz stimmt
wir können uns schon vereinigen nach
wirklich so auf molekularer also wie
können kinder machen also dass das
können nicht alle menschen aber
zumindest wird es gemacht manchmal
da ist eine aufhebung des das indes
kontinuums also da der doggen zwei wesen
an und machen zusammen etwas aber sonst
sind wir doch recht abgetrennt und leben
auch von dieser abgetrennt und um
kämpfen sind und haben haben viele
viel und und und ya bauen heute
festungen drum rum aber dass das
virtuelle sich verbinden ist ja wirklich
ganz
seien ja ein ganz wichtiges thema gabi
für jede kultur und und gerade da in
diesem sinne ist die see ist da weiß man
halt mann ist eine insel und bleibt eine
insel und das ist das wird niemand je so
wahrnehmen man kann es danach
beschreiben und kann es abstrakt
irgendwie aufzeichnen
aber ja es ist also das ist führt ein
vor die komödie des vereinzelt sei es
dass das allein bleiben es mit seinen
empfindungen dass das das ist die stadt
das ist
das ist der bedeutsam ist in dieser art
von wahrnehmung glaube ich oder die
bedeutet die nach erzielbare der
zählbare teil oder der der für andere
interessant ist und dann der rest ist
ist das wo man einfach dann so die augen
schließt und irgendein sich ein wort ich
habe mir mal ein wort auf und genießt
wie seltsames aussieht in in seiner
ästhetischen gestalt beispiel ein wort
wie opossums überhaupt ein tolles worden
allein das ist das klavier wird jeder
zustimmen dass das wort opossum wirklich
eine schöne schönen klang hat aber in
meinem kopf zufällig durch durch die
dieselben und durch auch die durch die
formen der buchstaben hat das eine
wirklich wohl es schaut aus wie so eine
bunte ein buntes saxophon mit ganz
vielen klappen also etwas ganz so endlos
so so s förmige schlängelt ist ein ganz
schrill verkleidete
seepferdchen so irgendwie ja und das ist
das genieße ich dann mal das kann jetzt
nach erzählen aber niemand wie man kann
das bild sehen so wie ich und auf und
vor allem so zu verteilt auf taktiles
und auf visuelles es geht geht einfach
mit assist und unübersetzbar in ein
medium das ein anderer mensch vielleicht
geht es irgendwie dann mal durch sein
nur link sache dass der elan maske hält
das ja für sehr wahrscheinlich dass wir
konzeptuelle telepathie machen werden
oder so
und es ging zwar völlig abgedreht jetzt
wenn man das hört sich irgendwie
politisch es auch für möglich vielleicht
geht es ja vielleicht sind wir gar nicht
so vereinzelte in sondern sind alle
total ähnliches im
betriebssystem vielleicht ist das so
jetzt sind wir sehr kompatibel und
wissen es halt nicht wir haben keine
keine laufwerke dafür noch
na ja ist es vielleicht auch so die ist
auch so die technik romantik unserer
zeit halt dass man solche gedanken hat
weiß und einstweilen wäre dann das
literarische schreiben oder das dichten
die vielleicht noch beste möglichkeit
dieses alleinsein und diese besondere
alleinseins erfahrung zu überwinden oder
gehe ich damit zu weit
naja die bessere alleinseins überwindung
ist eine an eine dann treibt also etwas
was so wie ein clown oder eine ein
freundeskreis eine intime größere
familie glaube ich dass das ist sicher
das bessere als schreiben und bücher
aber
es ist auch es ist schon eine der guten
und auch ökonomischen möglichkeiten also
dass man durch sprache einander so
beeinflusst dass man das bewusstsein
sich verändert und es das bewusstsein
sich auch annähernd das schon ja das
geht aber natürlich hat aber dann schon
eine sehr starke einen einen einen
schatten würden die die jungen würde die
jungs viel psychologie sagen also
eine dämonische seite nämlich die
propaganda das lügen dass das
manipulieren von menschen menschenmassen
und so weiter das ist leider das selbe
letztendlich das wird noch halt dann mit
verschiedenen vorzeichen mit
verschiedenen
verschiedenen graden der
soziopath i halt betrieben denke ich und
dass es aber es ist leider das selbe und
darum sind vielleicht auch große
schriftsteller können das ruhig mal auch
mal so generisch männliches formulieren
weil sie überdurchschnittlich männer
waren anfällig für genau das für das in
den dienst der propaganda kippen oder
das sich als als die die die starts
hypnotika fühlen oder leute dass man das
dass sie auch so die menschheit heilen
wollen und so gerade bei den größten
unter anführungszeichen also diese die
berühmtesten war das immer extrem stark
vorhanden also es ist sicher ein
schatten dem radar hat also eine eine
eine eine kleine kipfer also eine
negative gekippt wurde vom man von der
von demselben
überwinden des getrennt science dass das
ist leider das selbe es ist nicht
auseinander zu halten und ich glaube
auch besonders schwer ist es zu
lebzeiten auseinanderzuhalten von für
den der das machte den glauben schon sie
machen immer das gleiche
also
aber ja ich würde also was immer da die
die gegenwart von menschen vorziehen der
gegenwart von büchern also es gibt ja
dieses diese berühmte sache wenn man
sagt welches buch würdest du auf eine
einsame insel mitnehmen
natürlich sagen alle werke von
shakespeare oder sie sagen irgendwas
origineller leistung eigentlich heißt ja
nur was würdest du gerne lesen aber wenn
man wenn man mal dieses typisch für
poesie typische verfahren anwendet und
etwas bisschen ernster nimmt als muss
eigentlich darf also wo man einfach den
sozialen die sozialen code mal ein
bisschen autistisch nicht vor zu
verstehen meint so okay ich bin die
frage jetzt bitter ernst sondern sage
ich ja dann ist die antwort ist ein
handbuch für das fliehen von einsamen
inseln für das entkommen also das ist
das nämlich mit auf die einsame insel
ich möchte zurück zur menschheit wieder
natürlich sagen naja okay dass das spiel
nicht richtig mitgespielt
klugscheißer aber ich meine damit was
wirklich ganz ernsthaft ist dann auch
ich finde bücher sollten niemals
menschen ersetzen und das können sie
aber wirklich das drohen sie auch immer
zu tun allein schon durch ihre
abschreckende viel vielzahl sie sind so
viele im leben von menschen jeder mensch
bist also nicht jeder mit aber ganz
viele besitzen mehr gute bücher als gute
freunde sind auch irgendwie wegschmeißt
fahrer schneller also bücher aber
trotzdem bücher sind haben auch etwas
dämonisches und ich meine ja auch
wirklich ganz ernst sie haben etwas
vereinnahmen des und
verdrängens und damit muss man halt
irgendwie koexistieren lernen und das
muss man auch manchmal vielleicht dann
auch wirklich irgendwie bekämpfen wenn
es zu viel wird und so ist meine ganz
ernst und sagt es auch zum schaden
meiner eigenen zunft verkauft nicht so
viele bücher
siemens setzte daten
ein wunderschöner aufruf zum schluss
allerdings möchten wir verweisen auf die
bücher die romane die erzählung und die
gedichte von clement setzte sie jetzt
doch bitte alle kaufen und lesen und
sich von ihnen vereinnahmen lassen bei
suhrkamp und im residenz verlag sind sie
erschienen zuletzt das sachbuch die
bienen und unsichtbare bei suhrkamp ein
nicht ganz sachbuch wir gerade gelernt
haben ein ihr erzählte roman über ein
thema über plan sprachen geht es hat 416
seiten und kostet 24 euro vielen vielen
dank lieber clemens setz nach wien für
das gespräch danke euch und es war ist
wirklich schön schön eure stimmen zu
hören
mehr zu clemens setz finden sie in den
schoß verlinkt und auf unserer seite
faz.net / bücher - podcast bücher mit
oui und dann haben wir noch versprochen
die lösung des literatur rätsels aus dem
september zu verraten und auch wer ein
exemplar der erkundung von sauberen
durch reverend gilbert weitaus der
anderen bibliothek gewonnen hat diesmal
hat tilman spreckelsen
wiedersehen mit brideshead von evelyn wo
erzählt aus der sicht von lady julia
flight gewonnen hat katharina bertele
aus nürnberg wir gratulieren wir danken
allen die beim literatur rätsel
mitgemacht haben und ganz besonders
danken wir der anderen bibliothek für
dieses wunderbare buch
zum vor freuen können wir ihnen
ankündigen während der buchmesse von
mittwoch bis sonntag wollen wir täglich
drei sonder folgen mit gesprächen mit
autorinnen und autoren vom stand der faz
veröffentlichen und dann ja dann ist es
für uns zeit nach ein bisschen mehr als
zwei jahren bücher podcast das
staffelholz weiterzugeben an kollegen
aus dem feld der faz die im november mit
neuen ideen und einem neuen programm auf
sendung gehen werden wir wünschen gutes
gelingen sind gespannt und wir hoffen
dass sie liebe hörerinnen und hörer es
auch sinn wir danken ihnen bedanken
ihnen fürs zuhören diesmal und fürs
zuhören in der ganzen zeit für ihr
feedback ihre begeisterung ihre
nachfragen ihre kritik für alles
eigentlich was uns über die e
mailadresse bücher podcast etwas de und
über den instagram account etwas bücher
erreicht hat dass beides mit geschrieben
wird müssen wir ihn ja gar nicht mehr
sagen es hat großen spaß gemacht mit
ihnen und auch für sie zu senden jetzt
können wir leider nicht mehr sagen bis
bald deswegen sagen wir vielen dank und
alles gute alles gute
[Musik]